افادت رويترز نقلا عن قائد القوات
الاوكرانيه قوله ان الاوضاع في بخموت صعبه
وان قواته تصدت لكل محاولات الاستيلاء على
المدينه من جهتها اكد رئيس شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
للغايه حيث يتشبث الاوكرانيون بكل متر
ويصلهم الدعم بدون توقف وان القوات
الاوكرانيه تدفع بامدادات لا نهايه لها
واضاف بريجوجل على حسابه في تيليجرام انه
مع تقدم القوات الى وسط باخموت تزداد
المعارك ضراوه
في الاثناء نشر المركز الاعلامي العسكري
لوزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بيانا يشرح فيه
اهميه الدفاع عن بخموت معتبرا ان القوات
الروسيه تركز عملياتها على منطقه دونيتسك
بهدف الوصول الى الحدود الاداريه لمنطقتي
دونيتسكو وزياده كثافه العمليات الهجوميه
في اتجاهات لمن ومرينكا
انضموا الينا من دروسكوفكا في جنوب
كراماتورز مراسل والجزيره حسان مسعود جبهه
حسان مرحبا بك معنا بدايه وجبهه بخموت لا
زالت تخطف الانظار واشتداد للمعارك في كل
متر
[موسيقى]
بالفعل سلمى مرحبا بك ايضا هذه هي الحاله
التي يصفها المسؤولون الاوكرانيون بانها
قلب الصراع في هذه الفتره باخمت التي تشهد
معارك شرسه وشديده تتحدث عنها البيانات
الرسميه كما يتحدث عنها الميدان نسمع بشكل
متواصل اصوات القصف والقصف المتبادل بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات
الروسيه على اطراف منطقه بخمه من عدد من
الاتجاهات حيث تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه
صدها لهجمات باتجاه باخموت من ثلاثه
اتجاهات مختلفه من الشمال والشرق
والجنوب وتحاول القوات الروسيه الالتفاف
ايضا باتجاه الغرب لكن القوات الاوكرانيه
تعلن بشكل متواصل انها تصد هذه الهجمات
وتقصف القوات الروسيه التي تحاول التقدم
بهذا
الاتجاه هذا الصباح اكدت هيئه الاركان
انها
تصدت عبر قواتها طبعا لاكثر من مئه هجوم
في المنطقه الشرقيه تحدثت عن تصديها
لهجمات شرسه باتجاه بخمه على عدد من
الاتجاهات داخل المدينه وكذلك على عدد من
الجبهات الاخرى في الشرق الاوكراني تحدثت
عن افديسكا عن
ايضا ليمن وكذلك عن افشال محاولات للتقدم
في منطقه
شرقيه
هذه الجبهات التي ما زالت مشتعله في منطقه
الشرق تحاول القوات الروسيه مد قواتها
بعدد جديد من المقاتلين وفقه حديث
هيئه الاركان في بيانها الصباحي لكن في
ذات الوقت فان ما يحدث في بخمه عنه
بيانات الرسميه وكذلك ما قاله الرئيس
الاوكراني خلال اليوم الماضي بانه يؤدي
الى خسائر بشريه كبيره بالاضافه الى خسائر
بالمعدات الرئيس الاوكراني تحدث عن اكثر
من 1100 قتيل روسي خلال اسبوع فقط من
المعارك في باخمت بالاضافه الى 1500 مصاب
خلال هذه المعارك ويضاف الى ذلك عدد كبير
من الاليات وشكر الجنود الذين يقومون بصد
الهجمات وبالحاق هذه الخسائر للقوات
الروسيه على هذه الجبهه وكذلك المركز
الاعلامي لوزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه كان قد
اكد خلال اليوم الماضي وهي اشاره ايضا
ملفته عندما قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تريد ان تركز الهجمات في منطقه بخمه باخمت
لالحاق اكبر عدد من الخسائر بالقوات
الروسيه بينما تشتت الانتباه عن جبهات
اخرى وهو ايضا ما نلاحظه خلال
المتابعات للتطورات الميدانيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقوم بصد الهجمات تقوم بالحاق
الخسائر كما تقول عند جبهه سباق موت وهنا
في الشرق بينما تتحدث عن هدفها بدفع
القوات الروسيه 20 كيلومترا على الاقل
خلال الفتره المقبله في منطقه خرسون في
الجنوب وهو ما اعلنت عنه المتحدث باسم
قياده عمليات الجنوب يوم امس حسان مسعود
ستكون معنا في المتابعه